[Musique]
en direct du canada cette entame canada
des studios de radio canada
international à montréal autour de la
table vous allez les voir dans quelques
instants apparaître telles des mirage
mais ça n'a rien à voir et que c'est pas
des fantômes c'est des bons copains
alors on commence par alice cette
semaine mon journaliste et fan et samir
ben jaafer est avec nous bonjour samir
ne vous limitez pas qui peut écouter
qu'il peut voir aussi aux invités qui
sont viennent ouais on a deux invités
sur ce qu'est aujourd'hui je passe deux
spécialistes d'une question de grande
actualité vous allez le voir nos
auditeurs nos téléspectateurs nous
internautes et tous les autres ne savent
pas qu'elles aient sujet démission
aujourd'hui
enfin plusieurs si vous écoutez en
direct vous le savez pas si vous
l'écoutez sursis nate points c'est à la
version youtube ou facebook rediffusé
évidemment vous le chat est sorti du sac
ici même en studio il ya un lion qui
connaît les détails de l'émission oui
parce que ça la mouche je sais que je
suis il y en a par deux fois touché un
moment
moi je ne suis pas dans vos secrets non
l'étude sera la seule qui va devoir
deviner un studio et tous les autres
évidemment qui nous regardent en direct
vont devoir regarder cette vidéo 5
images qui contient le secret de
l'émission aujourd'hui le sujet on
regarde ça ensemble
cinq images c'est pas évident cette
semaine allez je vous le dis là c'est
vraiment pas évident faut faire utilisez
vos connaissances générales
vos connaissances peut-être je vous
donner un indice des couleurs elle peut
être bonne si ce n'est pas un âge est ce
qu'on n'est pas est-ce que c est ce que
c'est ce qu'ils répondent par oui ou par
non à ça vous êtes en algérie bah oui le
peuple demande toujours plus de
démocratie dans ce pays là oui bravo à
les salles à traiter du sujet ont dit
'nous on a le trac au nom de
soulèvements populaires l'algérie
demeure sous pression policière ces
modems aujourd'hui d'accord et puis
comme dit pressions policières et aussi
des militaires dans tout ça à l'arrière
de tout ça il ya les militaires et puis
on va parler de ça avec des spécialistes
mais avant tout plaisir à l'émission de
vous recevoir un vendredi nous c'est
comme c'est comme la récréation oui on
est seul on a la grosse boule elle va
tourner trois fois l'émission c'est la
tradition et à chaque tour de la grosse
boule vous perdez des points et vous
perdez de plus en plus de points aux
firmes de l'édition programme apprendre
des choses c'est ce qui est bien avec ma
quevelly c'était mon petit frère
alors on va pouvoir garder la première
question aujourd'hui avoir des craintes
je vous avertis un conteur 59 secondes
pour répondre donc si vous savez pas de
quoi vous parlez
on va vite se sentir voici la question
top chrono laquelle de ces affirmations
et la plus juste
le chrono est pas parti attention là
mais il devrait partir on va vous en
fais rien ou d'utiliser ya plus de
marocains claude algérien et du tunisien
la plus âgée que de tunisie ou du maroc
à l'avancé il ya de la logique il ya des
excès si c'est ça oui y'a plus tard et
c'est dire à tous les sas et au canada
l'algérie et puis en tunisie et puis au
maroc musiciens des populations dans
l'est c'est très exactement de tunis a
beaucoup de secondes pour répondre aux
deux marocains tunisiens que 2010
ben oui c'est le sait rien c'est le cslc
scène jette sur deux ça oui c'est le ccc
leucémie était pas de tourner
vous aussi
oui oui parce que il ya là et il ou
encore deux secondes c'est moi je dis
c'est ok alors félicitations vous avez
tous les toits d'abord de réponse
malheureusement alors en algérie ias 41
millions d'habitants et aux marocains à
35 millions et au en tunisie y en a 11
millions alors la bonne réponse
effectivement il ya plus d'algériens que
deux tunisiens et noir coup de main ou
de maroc massif où la question s'est
trompé de ballast c'est con parce que si
on a et ça devient inclusif ses trousses
et l'excusé le sud algérien que le
marocain et de tunisiens crise
ça fait une addition comme ça une
agression avec sissoko est excellente en
cours de français en gras merde on a
pris des cours des logiques de match je
dois vous dire allez j'ai dû y penser
très fort aux questions cette semaine
parce qu'il est d'origine algérienne est
aussi journaliste ces deux défauts on en
réchappe parfois d'échappée j'ai dû
poser des questions ou zèle dit quand
même des chances de pas ça va bien vous
gardez vos 20 points on va aller quand
même plus sérieusement parler de
politique pas seulement algérienne aussi
la diaspora canadienne des diasporas
algériens de renom qui participent qui
ont fait des efforts on a même ici au
canada une réalisatrice à montréal
d'origine âge
rien qui a fait un documentaire très
engagé là dessus on va lui parla plus
tard à nice
mais pour le moment on se tourne vers
monsieur ce milieu là même à qui j'ai
parlé récemment
non je pense pas j'en passe vous avez
parlé avec qui récemment j'ai parlé avec
une réalisatrice qui parlait de
l'immolation par ça c'était au début du
mouvement vraiment c'était au moment où
l'action a commencé c'était c'était ma
les mots ça fait pratiquement tout a
commencé il ya un an le 22 février
c'était bien avant c'était je crois un
mois avant non non c'est être c'était
vraiment un roman ça a commencé
non ça n'avait même pas encore commencé
je me souviens que je lui ai posé là
qu'est ce que c'est ça que ça commence à
bouger jours exactement et elle m'a dit
oui il est là il veut pas partir et
c'est pour cette raison que les jeunes
sont mécontents et justin peut ainsi
qu'en partie la révolution
d'ailleurs l'une de ces questions
d'examen ça m'avait surpris à l'époque
on dira qu'elle avait senti que ça
allait que ça bouge et alice elle
m'avait surpris à ce moment là elle
était vraiment en phase avec le
mouvement populaire qui n'était pas
encore déclenché mais elle se sentir
ainsi c'est parce qu'elle a une
expérience journaliste exactement est là
est ce qu'on est prêt pour recevoir
accueillir à l'émission temps canada
notre invité monsieur chennoufi on me
dit qu'il faut que je brode encore
pendant quelques secondes c'est dommage
et pas apporté ce que j'aime faire le
soir à la maison
tricotage govou non mais ce n'est plus
un tabou
moi je croisais désordre dans les bus
qui faisait avec des aiguilles comme ça
pourquoi ce temps j'en ai croisé y
serment rien puis
vous n'avez pas eu peur j'ai pas eu peur
non je me suis dit que non il ya mais
reste dans le métro oui j'en ai vu un
jeu les vu une ou deux fois pire il a
disparu je sais pas pour quelle raison
par contre on à la mairesse de d'un des
arrondissements de montréal qui à un
moment qu'est ce qu'elle faisait c'est
une race très engagé s'intéresse
activement fait ministre est ce qu'elle
faisait à chaque fois qu'elles n'ont pas
elle tricotait avec la couleur rouge et
chaque fois qu'une femme me parle
pendant la côte est et pour voir pour
voir que les ans prenait plus de death
passe dans l'espace public que les
femmes même et ça c'est la marque de
fabrique de cette mairesse
d'arrondissement
elle est géniale et d'en sortir le jeu
je peux vous ramenez maintenant vers le
centre-ville simplement que vous ne
touchez un mot avant d'aller vers notre
invité sur la diaspora au québec au
canada algérienne vous avez vous allez
côtoyer vous êtes desservir la vie j'ai
les anciennes de montréal ce que je
parle de ceux de montréal mais un peu
partout au canada
que ce soit à ottawa ou bien à québec on
doit depuis le début du mouvement
populaire anp le 22 le 22 février 2019
il ya eu à montréal chaque semaine
chaque fin de semaine une manifestation
oui quand je vous dis on est à la 55 ans
et 24e
mais là en face à la 54e ce deuxième
semaine d'abord aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
en argent c'est la 54e semaine et à
montréal aussi demain donc à montréal il
ya pratiquement deux manifs par semaine
une une le samedi en face du consulat et
une autre à la place du canada à
montréal et c'est vraiment c'est les
mêmes slogans
les gens ça c'est du soutien pour la
révolution du ce qu'on appelle la
révolution du sourire mais en même temps
les gens discutent aussi il faut pas que
ils font pas que manifester ya aussi des
forums de discussion sur les
possibilités de sortie de crise en
anglais
sur le moment là et comment la diaspora
peut aider ce mouvement est par exemple
pendant tout le pendant toute cette
période les grands événements de large
avait par exemple on a eu une grande
manifestation à l'occasion de la fête de
la fête du déclenchement de la
révolution gérer un site est le 2 le 2
le 1er novembre
et ça a commencé avec le 2 novembre et
on a aussi une grande manifestation qui
a traversé tout montréal le samedi
dernier c'était le dimanche dernier à
l'occasion du la preuve du premier
anniversaire de ce premier anniversaire
de du déclenchement de cette révolution
des boutiques et des partis un peu il
est parti le 2 il est parti le 2 avril
mais le déclenchement de la révolution
c'était le 22 février ce qui ce qui est
bien mais alors qu'est ce qui fait
problème en ce moment écoute parce que
parce que toutes les revendications ne
sont eux non pas été effectif et je
pense que notre invité va nous en parler
ça c'est le néo deux invités vont nous
en parler et ça c'est l'une de mes
questions armes a aussi beaucoup de
questions moi j'attends les réponses
comme vous mais ce que je trouve amusant
c'est qu'on va quand vous dites notre
invité vous savez pas lequel des 2 1
oui c'est moi non plus d'ailleurs mais
ça va c'est la solution invités parle du
même sujet oui j'espère oui mais des
perspectives mais l'apport il est
différent la preuve les différentes
images on va d'abord avoir le point de
vue engagé d'accord je vous avais promis
n'ont trouvé que un professeur
universitaire on va commencer par le
point de vue engagé celui de nasser
sarah nasser réalisatrice ici à montréal
montréalaise d'origine algérienne
bonjour ça va
bonjour alors pendant qu on va se parler
nous avons extrait de deux d'une
publicité qu'ils avaient sur youtube des
images de votre documentaire pour qu'on
son convoi les gens dans la rue
manifester les images que vous avez
capté c'est je voulais d'abord vous
demandez quand vous avez une idée de
tourner ce reportage où ce documentaire
est ce que vous étiez là bas déjà où
vous étiez ici vous avez réagi alain
faut que j'aille sur le terrain ben en
fait c'est assez drôle parce que ça
s'est décidé lors de
une émission à radio canada j'avais été
invité pour débattre de la situation
j'ai été d'ailleurs très surprise de
recevoir un appel parce que à ce moment
là j'étais pas forcément dans les rues
de montréal en train de manifester mais
bon j'étais reconnu pour mes
implications culturelles au sein de la
communauté algérienne et c'est lors de
ce débat et c'est sûr surtout suite à ce
débat au niveau de radio-canada et à la
réaction de plusieurs collègues qui
m'ont dit qu'ils venaient de découvrir
un pays qui ne connaissait pas que j'ai
pris conscience du momentum qui était
d'aller immortaliser ce mouvement et que
c'était aussi l'occasion pour le monde
de découvrir cette algérie qu'on ne
montre pas forcément dans les médias et
qu'on ne connaît pas forcément
et donc j'étais à montréal et puis j'ai
pris un j'ai pris un billet d'avion je
suis descendu alger vivre le mouvement
et l'immortalisa travers ce documentaire
le titre qui va de tous ça rappelle un
peu le fameux dégagisme dont on parle
tant celle de gansu et tout le monde va
partir
c'est à dire que toute l'équipe est
pourri parce que là dedans est ce qu'il
n'ya pas de bongrain bah écoutez le
titre tout le monde le sait d'où il
vient le titre s'est en fait c'est ce
mot ce cri du coeur du jeune sofiane qui
avait fait un vox pop mais au fait qui
avait qui étaient apparues au milieu
d'une émission d'une entrevue au fait il
faut remettre les choses dans le
contexte qui s'est passé c'est que
lorsque d'abord bouteflika a annoncé
qu'il renonçait à la à la candidature au
cinquième mandat
il y avait une télévision étrangère je
pense si télévision du moyen-orient qui
avait envoyé une photo c'est ça une
correspondante dans les rues d'alger
pour montrer un peu la réaction des
algériens et cette correspondante disait
que les algériens étaient satisfaits et
qui est qu'il se félicitait donc de des
résultats et de la démission du
président et donc sofiane c'est un jeune
algérois qui passait par là et en
entendant ça c'est venu le chercher
profondément et il est il est rentré au
beau milieu de cette entrevue il a coupé
l'entrevue pour dire non on n'est pas
satisfait et donc bon au début elle a
voulu le mettre de côté mais ils ont vu
qu'ils pouvaient pas
décidez de l'interviewer lui donner la
parole et c'est extraordinaire parce que
ce que sofiane a fait en trente secondes
c'est la résumer toute la situation en
algérie est bien plus c'est à dire qu'il
a dit non n'est pas satisfait ils n'ont
fait que remplacer un pion par un pion
dans qui l'avait bien compris que le
système avait c'est lui qui faisait
l'échiquier qui joue avec l'échiquier
que bouteflika n'était qu'un finalement
et en finalement elle lui a dit il a
sorti cette phrase extraordinaire yotine
à ouga donc que j'ai traduit par qu'ils
partent tous mais ça aurait pu être plus
fort en disant qu'ils dégagent tous
parce que c'est vraiment ça que les gens
veulent et c'est devenu le sophie elle
est devenue un peu l'icône de la
révolution
et cette phrase est devenue un peu le je
vais te dire le montra le mantra de
cette révolution du sourire et on veut
que qu'ils partent tous c'est ça que
c'est ça que les algériens dionne que le
système tel qu'il est partie et laisse
la place à quelque chose de nouveau à
une démocratie au fait ça va vous n'êtes
pas appuyé par une organisation
médiatique vous êtes une productrice
indépendante j'imagine quels sont les
risques que vous prenez
si vous deviez par exemple vous
retourner en algérie faire un autre
documentaire sur la situation de ces
prisonniers politiques puisque
maintenant il n'y a pas d'autre
on peut pas décrire la situation
différemment le régime a dit on a libéré
des gens ne vous en faites pas mais
derrière la machine et et cachot
continuer à rouler si vous deviez vous
retourne peut retourner là bas
est-ce que vous prendriez les risques
est ce que c'est une société vraiment où
il ya des dangers pour les gens qu'ils
veulent faire des pressions de
l'extérieur comme vous l'a écouté c'est
sûr que moi avant de sortir mon film je
me suis posé plein de questions et pas
pour moi parce que moi j'habite à
montréal au pire je rentre pas en
algérie pendant une période et puis
c'est tout ce que je risque par contre
j'ai pensé vraiment aux personnages aux
gens qui ont pris la parole dans mon
film qui parle qui ont participé à ce
documentaire qui se sont exprimés je les
ai tous contacté plusieurs fois avant de
sortir le film pour leur dire est-ce
qu'ils étaient toujours d'abord en
accord avec ce qu'ils avaient dit en
face de la camy face à la caméra et j'ai
appelé aussi mon ami qui a produit le
documentaire et je lui ai dit c'est toi
qui prend le plus de risques c'est en
ans qui à la production en a tourné sans
autorisation de tournage on a fait ce
documentaire
avec une caméra à la main et il m'a dit
écoute sahara nous on assume tout en
aidant les rues chaque vendredi pour le
crier haut et fort alors vas-y sort ce
documentaire est donc à partir du moment
où les gens m'en donner l'autorisation
de mon côté moi je n'avais pas peur
c'est vrai que à partir du moment le
documentaire est sorti que j'ai pris
même la parole sur d'autres chaînes sur
d'autres médias
on m'a suggéré fortement de ne pas
descendre en algérie à ce moment là mais
depuis honnêtement moi si j'ai
l'occasion je descendrai en algérie mon
rêve c'est de projeter ce film en
algérie de pouvoir le projeter au public
parce que c'est vraiment c'est à eux
qu'il appartient ce documentaire je suis
actuellement en train de faire une
demande officielle au ministère pour
avoir l'autorisation de le tourner parce
que je fais j'essaie de faire les choses
un peu correctement à partir du moment
où est-ce qu'ils ont décrété que le 22
février dans qu'est la date de
déclenchement de cette révolution du
sourire ils ont décrété que c'était une
journée nationale donc ils ont joué un
peu sur cette date
alors ne manquez indigeste c'est ça le
gouvernement a décrété alors je pars du
principe que le gouvernement reconnaisse
cette révolution alors je leur demande
d'autorisation de de diffuser ce film
qui parle de cette révolution qui l'a
reconnu donc moi aussi je sais tu es
concerne je vois et pour finir j'ai
dédié man film à aux détenus d'opinion
parce que quand j'ai tourné en algérie
il n'y avait pas autant de de répression
c'est en était encore aux premières
semaines de cette révolution du sourire
et j'ai aussi dédier ce film et je tiens
à le dire à un jeune
ramzy et tout un jeune de blida donc de
la périphérie d'alger qui est venu
manifester avec ses amis à vendredi et
qui n'est jamais rentré chez lui jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas ce qui est
arrivé il ya encore une enquête qui ont
apparemment en cours mais selon beaucoup
de sources concordantes
il aurait été bastonné par par
l'harmonie c'est exactement ça et donc
ce jeune pour moi c'est le jeune martyr
de la révolution ils alim
c'est très symbolique c'est un jeune et
on dit que cette révolution des sourires
et porté aussi par beaucoup de jeunes
donc c'est à lui que j'ai rendre que
jeux dédiés et que j'ai dédié ce
documentaire pour que pour que nul
n'oublie
ce jeune qui est mort aux premières
semaines de la révolution ça
sarah nassar vous avez parlé de
projection tout à l'heure en algérie
mais mais mais l'on voudrait bien je
voudrais bien que vous nous parler de la
projection de votre film ici au canada
comment ça comment il a été accueilli
par le public et j'imagine que le public
il y avait certainement des membres de
la diaspora algérienne est aussi des
canadiens si on peut dire que ce soit
des québécois ou bien d'autres
communautés
mais en fait moi j'ai été très très très
surprise de l'accueil parce que au
départ je m'attendais à faire un film et
est loué une salle à montréal et le
projeter juste comme ça aux proches
parce que je ne lui avait pas donné tout
toute cette valeur que finalement il
porte en lui parce que on est toujours
auto critique par rapport à son travail
c'est mon premier film donc je vais je
n'ai pas vraiment le montrer comme ça au
public
et finalement j'ai un de mes collègues
qui a contacté la cinémathèque et qui
leur a dit on a une jeune collègue
réalisatrice il vient de faire un film
sur un sujet d'actualité et il en vue et
ils ont carrément décidé de le
programmer donc à la cinémathèque
c'était prévu moi je m'attendais à ce
que ce soit une seule journée donc
j'avais choisi symboliquement la journée
du 11 décembre parce que c'était la
veille des élections en algérie mais
aussi parce que le 11 décembre est une
journée en algérie historique c'est une
journée le 11 décembre
donc je samir peut-être pourra me je
pense que c'est en 61 si je me trompe
pas les algériens s'en sortent en
décembre 61 les algériens sont sortis
dans toutes les rues d'alger algérie
pour demander a donc enfin pour demander
la fin de la colonisation française et
donc la fin de la guerre et j'ai choisi
cette date
historiquement le 11 décembre pour ma
première projection à montréal la salle
s'est remplie en quelques heures et du
coup on a eu énormément de projection ça
fait ça fait sold out pendant huit
séances à la cinémathèque et il ya eu
énormément de weeds algérien et puis ça
ouvre le débat bien sûr les algériens
sont connus pour aimer les débats pour
piller ya eu aussi beaucoup de gens qui
ne sont pas forcément non seulement ils
sont pas forcément algérien mais ils
n'ont pas forcément de lien avec
l'algérie et ils sont venus par
curiosité pour découvrir un peu ce cette
révolution de l'intérieur et j'ai été
très très très surprise et agréablement
surprise par la paix parce que j'ai
des gens sortir de la salle en pleurant
et pas forcément des algériens et je
pense que le message de ces jeunes que
je porte dans le documentaire est passé
c'est un message du coeur c'est de
l'authenticité c'est quelque chose qui a
été filmé sans aucun casting
ça a été vraiment pris à chaud au coeur
d'une de la révolution et le message je
pense à a su toucher rejoindre les gens
ici à montréal
merci sarah juste une précision le 11
décembre 1960 juste pour m'excuser
n'étaient pas les mêmes c'était un
compliment passe à écouter merci
beaucoup sarah nasser peut-être venu à
cette émission d'avoir mis la table pour
les autres qui vous qui vont qui vont
vous suivre merci beaucoup merci à vous
voilà et je l étais de 500 m 800 m de
nos studios
d'un autre côté de la viva technologies
wells à z on va aller maintenant très
loin on va aller à toronto qui est à
environ 500 kilomètres de montréal
c'est un ses parents m ouais c'est ça
bon bah c'est facile c'est 100 fois plus
1000 fois plus j'en suis sûr donc ça
fait 5000 m c'est ça oui ça tombe 1500
1500 1000 m ah oui c'est vrai autre
chose que ce n'est pas bon en maths on à
monsieur minouflet chez nous philippe
nucho niveau et demi le tchèque était
avec nous finalement bonjour comment ça
va bonjour à vous bonjour à vous je veux
quand même préciser vous êtes bien à
toronto se trompent pas là dessus un
claquement exactement et puis aussi
froid c'est vrai écoutez là et c'est pas
qu'on parle pas de chaleur en algérie on
va parler de climat politique tout de
même moi je regarde ça
avec un an de détachement on a vu les
soulèvements populaires nous en parlions
beaucoup à radio-canada d'ailleurs j'ai
fait un tour dans les archives de
radio-canada c'est à ce moment là qu'on
voit l'algérie à la télévision aux
présentes ça au canadien après ça pas
grand chose bon on va retenir coûte
d'affaires président bouteflika se
retire on a eu un général qui prend sa
place
il ya des élections présidentielles
annoncées en décembre
il ya quelqu'un qui est élu ça fait pas
la sphère de la population il ya un
général qui est mort entre temps le même
général et depuis ce temps là bas on
découvre et là on commence à voir des
reportages qu'il ya de la répression
policière militaire que les choses sont
pas ce qu'elles sont maintenant plus
grave qu'elle ne l'était sous bouteflika
on peut pas dire on ne peut absolument
pas dire cela à partir du moment où
malgré les arrestations politiques qui
sont tout à fait problématique et puis
les détenus politiques bien entendu
doivent être libérés c'est une
revendication tout à fait légitime et
bien le type de manifestation que nous
voyons aujourd'hui chaque semaine dans
les rues d'alger était assez impensable
sous la présidence de boue train avait
une interdiction par la loi de
manifester dans la rue alors que
aujourd'hui nous en voyons deux par
semaine une le vendredi et une le mardi
alors de ce point de vue là il y a une
différence assez fondamental maintenant
reste la question des détenus politiques
et reste le reste des questions liées
aux mouvements populaires qui doivent
être adressées effectivement considérer
l'algérie aujourd'hui comme une nation
démocratique étant donné que les gens
continuent à se plaindre si les gens se
pincer qui a un problème de fond il ya
un problème quelque part qui perdure
qu'est ce qui fait problème selon vous
aujourd'hui et qu'est ce qu'on devrait
faire pour que la démocratie soit
véritablement en marche dans ce pays
vous savez pour moi la démocratie n'est
pas un stade final n'est pas un stade de
défini c'est toujours un processus
même dans les démocraties qui sont
établies elles peuvent connaître un
surcroît de démocratie ou des
régressions dans la démocratisation
comme on le voit aujourd'hui un peu
partout en occident sous
le sous le coup des mouvements
populistes et avec un recul des droits
démocratiques en algérie il y a il y à
un processus un processus qui est très
long qui s'est enclenchée ça fait ça
fait une bonne trentaine d'années et qui
a connu des avancées qui a connu des
reculs mais on peut dire que depuis
l'année dernière c'est une avancée dans
le bon sens delà de la démocratisation
le problème c'est que nous sommes encore
loin de toutes les étapes qui sont
nécessaires pour arriver à une véritable
démocratie
il y a bien entendu les blocages qui
viennent du pouvoir politique mais il y
a également les limites du mouvement
populaire lui même un petit du point de
vue de la mobilisation est irréprochable
puisque la mobilisation est encore très
vivace mais qui reste très limité en
matière de structuration en matière
d'organisation et en matière de
propositions concrètes vers un
changement ordonné vous savez le fameux
slogan dont vous avez discuté il y a un
instant il faut qu'ils partent tous est
un slogan politique est très accrocheur
très mobilisateur mais en matière de
programmes de changement il n'a pas
beaucoup de sens parce que qu'est-ce que
ça signifie qu'il faut que tout le monde
parte puisqu'on sait que le pouvoir en
algérie où reposent sur un certain
nombre d'institutions
est-ce qu'il faut que ces institutions
pas si ces institutions par
l'instabilité qui est créé notamment
avec un affaiblissement de de
l'institution militaire est ce que les
gens qui revendiquent ce genre de
changement anton - un plan dans leur
tête pour assurer assurer la relève et
il c'est sur ce point là précisément
qu'il y a qu il ya un blocage puisque il
n'existe pas dans le mouvement populaire
pour le moment de propositions concrètes
même si je nous fais est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut que le ce qu'on
appelle le mouvement populaire ac doit
se structurer
est-ce que c'est primordial pour vous
par rapport à votre analyse politique
est-ce que c'est nécessaire ou c'est
obligatoire qu'il y ait une
structuration pour que ça puisse avancer
impératif vous pouvez envisager toutes
les expériences historiques de
démocratisation que ce soit en espagne
en grèce en turquie et en indonésie en
inde ou ailleurs où on amérique latine
également et vous allez voir que
toujours là de la démocratisation s'est
manifestée ou s'est concrétisée lorsque
les porteurs de cette démocratisation
était structuré a nécessairement dans
une seule et unique structure puisque le
mouvement populaire et très plurielle
donc il faut qu'ils représentent toutes
les sensibilités qui qui existe
et puis toutes les expériences de
démocratisation se sont faites aussi
grâce à des partenaires qui existait
dans les systèmes politiques précédents
ok donc il n'y a pas eu il n'y a pas eu
de très rarement en fait un départ une
un effondrement si vous voulez du du
système qu'on va remplacer par quelque
chose d'autre il ya toujours eu
si vous voulez un rapport transactionnel
entre ceux qui voulaient un changement
et ceux qui étaient dans le système et
qui ont accompagné également le
changement c'est ce qui doit se produire
en algérie un dernier mois là dessus si
le mouvement populaire ne se structure
pas de façon innovante et de façon à
exprimer cette note ce nouvel élan
notamment celui de la jeunesse est bien
à l'intérieur du mouvement il y à des
groupes organisés qui avance masqué avec
leur propre agenda qui cherche
effectivement à récupérer ce mouvement
et s'emparer du pouvoir sans élection à
la manière de ce qui s'est passé dans
certains pays avec des conséquences
totalement de la france vous pensez à un
régime c'est ça non je ne pense pas à
l'egypte parce que en egypte au moins il
ya eu des élections
mais c'est vrai que les frères musulmans
qui ont
raf les amis si vous voulez en egypte
n'était pas derrière le mouvement
populaire ils n'étaient pas derrière le
mouvement populaire ils ont ils ont
rejoint le mouvement quand c'était
devenu si vous voulez sans risque et
ensuite ils ont voulu tout ramasser et
en et en ramassant tous ils ont recréé
une polarisation qui a fini par amener
les militaires par la fenêtre alors que
on avait essayé de les faire sortir par
la porte
alice mais c'est en fait dans chaque
dans toute révolution il ya des intérêts
divergents qui s'affrontent
les jeunes aussi ont leurs intérêts ils
ont leurs doléances à soumettre au début
de cette émission je parlais d'un
entretien que j'ai eu avec une jeune
réalisatrice algérienne mais camacho
bouakaz voilà elle me parlait me
décrivait la situation d'une jeunesse
totalement déboussolée désorienté sans
emploi en perte de repères des jeunes
qui étaient parfois obligés de s'immoler
par le feu
comme ultime solution pour sortir un de
leurs de la vicissitude que la vie leur
impose dans ce pays là ben ils
essayaient de suivre le modèle de ce
jeune marchand de fruits tunisien il
s'appelait qui s'était immolé par le feu
parce qu'il est tout simplement dépassés
par la situation dans son pays
est ce qu'aujourd'hui là on peut
redonner espoir à ces jeunes algériens
disons d'abord que les griefs qui sont
exprimées par la jeunesse ou par
d'autres pans de la société algérienne
sont la plupart du temps tout à fait
tout à fait légitime donc de ce point de
vue là est absolument indiscutable
maintenant pour répondre à ces doléances
il s'agit il est absolument nécessaire
d'avoir un programme une vision une
structure arrivé au pouvoir par des
moyens légitimes et mettre en oeuvre ses
plans c'est politicus et où ces
stratégies
donc le problème n'est pas du tout que
les doléances ou les griefs ne soit pas
légitime ils le sont absolument ce qui
manque à la jeunesse en algérie c'est
c'est de s'organiser politiquement et la
politique ce n'est pas uniquement des
cris du coeur les cris du coeur sont
importants sont absolument nécessaires
parce que
c'est avec ça qu'on se mobilise et c'est
avec ça qu'on reste vigilant mais il
faut qu'ils y l'apprentissage de quelque
chose de plus et de quelque chose de
plus qu'il faut qu'il faut apprendre
c'est à se structurer à s'organiser et à
se doter d'un programme à à se présenter
comme une alternative
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
mouvement populaire a cessé d'intéresser
le monde et les médias dans le monde
c'est tout simplement parce que le
pouvoir en algérie est capable donc de
véhiculer ce message à l'égard des
partenaires étrangers en disant au moins
moi j'ai un plan je suis ou est-ce que
je vais voilà les étapes de ce que je
veux réaliser pour retourner à la
stabilité alors qu'on fasse de moi je
j'ai vu ce qu'une masse de gens qui sont
dans la rue et qui sont incapables de
présenter un plan bien articulé qui soit
suffisamment réaliste pour se présenter
en alternative et c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis le départ du président
bouteflika
la réalité c'est qu'on est au delà de la
mobilisation de la rue c'est le pouvoir
qui gagne une dernière question
oui monsieur nouvelles chaque mouvement
populaire de cette envergure
généralement ça n'arrive pas chaque
chaque année dans une mélasse et ça ça
dure depuis une année qu'est ce que vous
prévoyez sur la durée est ce que ça va
encore continuer comme ça où est ce que
ce que ça va s'essouffler ou est-ce que
ça va d'autres ça va avoir un autre
regard est avancé par l'amant
en fait c'est toujours très difficile de
prévoir l'avenir mais une chose est
certaine en algérie qu'on a connue sous
le nom but notamment les dix dernières
années ça c'est un passé révolu
aucun mal géré une reviendra là dessus
c'est une
c'est une certitude maintenant pour le
mouvement populaire il y est différente
il ya différentes directions possibles
l'essoufflement est un risque et ce
serait vraiment dommage que ce mouvement
s'essouffle ce n'est pas ce n'est pas du
tout souhaitable
ce qui par contre souhaitable et qui
possible aussi c'est que on s'organise
de telle sorte à pouvoir peser dans les
élections parce qu'il y aura des
élections
donc il faut s'organiser pour pouvoir à
la fois participer aux élections et
aussi les contrôles et de telle sorte
que si elles ne sont pas faits ne se
déroule pas dans des conditions
démocratiques
il est possible de les remettre en cause
par la suite donc pour moi pour pour
pour l'avenir et une avenue positive
possible serait d'avancé sur deux lignes
la ligne de la mobilisation continue et
la ligne de la structuration de
l'organisation et de la proposition de
programme comme alternative à dire que
donc voilà enfin c'est une fille
vraiment vous aviez une autre rue bien
bien organisé vous
on apprécie on a compris le message et
le message est clair il faut s'en faut
préparer la structure faut pour faire
des propositions très claires qui
s'accordent avec les vrais besoins de
nation plutôt que de simplement vivre
avec les cris du coeur parce que ça ça
aide mais ça ne même pas sa valise sans
mobiliser lendemain il faut fonder un
projet alors merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé aujourd'hui à l'émission et
puis on va féliciter
bell canada de nous avoir secourus grâce
aux téléphones pouvoir vous parler sinon
non
merci merci beaucoup à vous à la
prochaine à la prochaine c'est certain
alors c'était miloud chennoufi du
département d'étude de la défense
collège des forces canadiennes à toronto
écoutez là son plaisir maintenant je
pense qu'on a bien compris notre leçon
et puis en grand c'est un peu comme à
l'école je vous pose des questions très
simples sur la géographie sur l'histoire
sur la démographie comme je lé fais plus
tôt alors considérez moi voyez moins en
moins professeurs on est venu apprendre
aux consoles de ce deuxième tour de la
grosse brute il ya combien de bouddha
père pour le deuxième tour on nous cache
rien il ya trente bull à perdre et vous
avez conservé vos vingt premières boules
donc le pire score aujourd'hui vous
pourriez avoir ses 80 n'en est pas le
pire c'est le meilleur bond à la
deuxième question de la grosse boule
aujourd'hui c'est très simple c'est une
question géographie moi je me rappelle
quand j'étais à l'école je dessinais les
chaîne montagneuse au nord de l'afrique
parce que j'étais à l'école française
soit 16 là parmi des lycéens et donc moi
je dessinais le petit atlas le grand
atlas à vous dit des choses
j'aimerais beaucoup dessiner les cours
de géographie et je pense que beaucoup
de désert dans votre pays
oui il voulait dire parce que c'est le
sable à ce que c'est les montagnes
rocheuses
c'est ce que c'est les montanari pour
sceller ces messieurs c'est le hockey
quel pourcentage la superficie de
l'algérie mais c'est sûr que c'est passé
si c'est 90% et du conte et du 62 70
qu'est ce qu'ils considéraient agira
avec 80% 80% b 80 % vous vous y allez
avec le voyage c'est vraiment au pif
parce que je trouve que 90 % 6 7%
j'ai bon se trouve pourtant c'est tout
c'est un grand oui c'est 2000 en plus
j'avais la donne et ses deux millions de
kilomètres carrés cette superficie du
sahara sur vous le savez ça ben écoute
j'ai fait moi
mais il est d'origine âge cm1 cm2 spurs
six canadiennes c'est le désert
présentement j'ai pas eu de réponse de
la part de samir j'ai eu une bonne
réponse de voir si c'est beau pas de
réponse c'est un jeu et samir
malheureusement il est en train de
spéculer jeter comme le magicien je vous
montrais c'est ça va seulement 30 points
perdus pour mieux s'abstenir
alors lieu pour le 3e jeu alors alice a
conservé tous ses points partout mais
bull
ouais et puis vous vous en avez perdu
que 30 l'intervention du dernier jeu de
les voir c'est une autre question très
facile pour alice impôts 6,9 en 2009
l'algérie comptait combien de fois moins
deux barrages que le canada hydro
électrique au barrage à la ba ouais
est-ce que c'était 200 fois moins
moi je dis ça écoute et sa répartie
connaissances générales devriez le
savoir est ce que c'était b400 fois où
est-ce que 3 8 5 fois le barrage la toux
barrage confondues wyss réussir un poids
mais pourquoi j'irais avec un maximum
bon si je vous dis qu'il ya 10000
barrage au canada ce que ça change votre
réponse ça te ferait des truies sont
sans restriction non ou si tu lis à
whisky oui c'est vous dites tous les 2
800 points
ils n'ont ils n'ont pas bien j'avais
encore 8 secondes pour changer votre
étrange non
j'ai seulement dit que persistent et
signent ici leur apprendre on est
supporter est bien
ça ressemble vous avez tous les doutes
alors il ya quand même beaucoup de bajur
y en a cinquante canada y en a dix mille
alors c'est quoi ces deux beaucoup plus
c'est quand on a appris une chose il ya
deux cents par action d'algérie et oui
mais non excusez moi qui viens du campo
non vous avez c'est au canada combien de
diminuer et en algérie 50
ouais 50 alors pourcentage et on était
autour de 800 euros tout de wiz arc de
feu monsieur exemple le pire c'est que
j'ai pris une calculatrice pour faire
5-2 face à la douleur
votre calculatrice
alors non je pense que si on fait un
tour à pied de façon sûre le temps pour
conserver toutes bourboule
merci mais bon on est prêt pour le jeu
blanc neigeux de la semaine ya rien à
perdre ou à gagner c'est la photo et
vous deviez définissez bayal sur mon
avis russe
il ya les traces des premières nations
c'est l'histoire
moi je réponds seulement ou pas ou par
non ok ça va
j'en ai voir ce que je pense pas que
je pense que oui au caire est ce que
c'est lire aux autres un nom ce palier
on n'aurait pas de traitement
ok est-ce que c'est lié au cours d'un
virus est-ce que c'est lewis est liée
aux corneilles parfaite oui il ya une
avance car il en a autour de l'image
l'image mais ça fait parler le nom que
les canadiens qui sortent du bateau non
c'est pas ça non sais pas si c'est pas
le cas présumés à mourir non ça viendra
pas de photo on n'a pas dit on n'a pas
de retour de la patiente
parce que l'image du corps humain il
courait navire le sait et fait partie de
l'histoire c'est au centre de l'histoire
mais ce que ces élus est-ce que c'est un
set un laboratoire où on a découvert le
nom mais c'est très technique c'est à
dire quelque chose de très technique
ouais ouais quelque chose du traité avec
beaucoup de mathématiques de dinde aux
chiffres il faut pas se tromper c'est
très dangereux de se tromper que ce
beaucoup de chez beaucoup de numéros
c'est un ordinateur qui calcule quelque
chose qui m les ordinateurs qui se
calcule en fait on s'est dit on n'a pas
de décompte c'est long mais j'espère que
j'ai pas vu cette image je vais vous
donner un indice tsx dadjo story la
crise et maintenant ça sent pas le
dindon c'est plus de deux ans maintenant
alors voici votre image la sema ok mais
bon je m'attendais au bloc en fin
bah oui on le retrait vers 10 ce matin
les marchés ont plongé encore et ont
atteint leur plus bas niveau historique
et j'ai aimé j'ai aimé le camp appelle
d'autres en fait des blagues à part moi
j'ai regardé avant l'émission en dix
minutes avant c'était 933 points de
moins ou d'argent disent que vous avez
la capacité de me dire combien on est
rendu à combien une habitante de perte
ou de gain ils ont tous regagné 933 soit
il prend plusieurs secondes voire une
alerte alors voilà on a perdu mon dieu
seulement 2 62% donc c'est pas si mal
comme journée va parler aux autres pour
ceux qui investissent ouais si vous avez
de l'argent vous n'êtes pas c'est
dommage avoir d'argent général c'est une
bonne chose mais la spéculation simple
ouais c'est trop tôt pour rire je sais
pardon c'est que c'est terrible c'est
que c'est
sellal et les gens qui voulaient partir
à la retraite tous à 6 ans au service de
tous ordres de fonds de retraite qui
sont alors l'idée c'est de d'investir
mais de faire attention quand tout va
bien va trop bien quand on écoute
certains politiciens
on croise les doigts c'est ça alors
écouter sérieusement on en parlera dans
le cadre de nos activités ici à radio
canada international de l'examiner plus
près ce que ça veut dire pour les
canadiens 7 jeu derrière si j'avais un
conseil à me donner se stabiliser c'est
ça d'actes manche parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire beaucoup de
choses à faire beaucoup de conseils à
donner
et beaucoup de conseils à suivre nous
mène dans cette histoire là d'ailleurs
merci à vous deux alice et puis samir
félicitations vous avez tous été
champions l'émission nous avons déjoué
le professeur et à la somme d'argent
[Musique]